الاجواء لا تقل الحراره واحتفاءا وفرحا عن
الرباط عن اي مدينه مغربيه ومدينه عربيه
هنا في الرياض حيث اجتمع العديد من
الجماهير سواء كان المغربيه او العربيه او
السعوديه للاحتفاء بهذه همم بهذا الانتصار
الكبير للمنتخب المغربي نحن هنا في احد
الشوارع الرئيسيه في الرياض حيث بعد
انتهاء مباشر مباراه مباشره انتقل الجمهور
الى هذا الشارع للاحتفاء وتحديدا شارع
التحليه ونلتقي بال مشجعين المغاربه اليوم
انتصار تاريخي يكلمنا عن شعورك وفرحك بهذه
الانتصار لما سوف
الو الساعه اخوي والله العظيم اخويا راح
القلب ديالي يسكت على هذا الماتش هذا
كنشكركم كاملين وكنشكر الراس لافوكا ضروري
نجم المباراه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والصراحه يمثل الشعب العروق والعربيه كلها
ههه
هذا المشجع رج- رجعه طيب ايش هي اللزوجه
اللي تقولها الان الجماهير السعوديه تحيه
مغربيه الجماهير السعوديه
[موسيقى]
يعني احنا كنا واحد يعني الدول العربيه
كلها كلنا واحد يعني
كلها الدول العربيه رونالدو
[موسيقى]